we had 68,000 hospitalizations I don't
so the four thousand number would be a
subset of that and I don't know what
information we have that we haven't
released at this point do you know no I
don't think there's any information that
we have that we haven't released at this
point but I just want to reiterate once
again that the policy that the
Department of Health put out was in line
directly with the March 13th directive
put out by CDC and CMS that read and I
quote nursing homes should admit any
individuals from hospitals where Kovac
is president not could should that is
president Trump's CMS and CDC so I know
that there's been a lot of discussion on
this topic there are over a dozen states
that did the exact same thing many of
whom were concerned about hospital
capacity at the time everybody remembers
the projections were well into the
hundred and forty thousand hospital bed
range whereas we started out with they
think it was about 50,000 and so
obviously any death is unfortunate death
but and even when you look at in
comparison to other states New Jersey
has five thousand five hundred and
twenty two confirmed nursing home deaths
whereas New York is 3094 Massachusetts
3755 Connecticut 1487 it's been a
national and international tragedy that
everybody has had to grapple with and it
is something that we're trying to learn
from every day and move forward yeah I
said let me just let me just come in
under the look we're in a political
environment here I get it I understand
it I'm a big big boy I can say all day
long
I refuse to politicize this discussion
and I have not and I will not because I
represent Democrats and Republicans and
independents and atheists and short
people and tall people and the politics
makes no difference to me I have no
political agenda I have no political
aspirations there's no politics here the
I can say that but we're still in an
election year and people are still
playing politics and this is a hyper
in environment to the extent people want
to politicize this issue and Republicans
are saying well New York did this New
York followed the president's agency's
guidance so that D politicize is it what
New York did was follow what the
Republican administration said to do
that's not my attempt to politicize it
it's my attempt to D politicize it so
don't criticize the state for following
the president's policy